all right well much more serious now I  spent the last few days in Iwo Jima and  Guam and you're allowed to go into Iwo  Jima one day a year for about six hours  it's now controlled once again by the  Japanese so I was part of the Steven  Ambrose military history tour the United  flight that we went in on was full of  veterans who are in their 90's that's me  on the top of Mount Suribachi it was  just an incredibly moving experience I'm  working on a book on Iwo Jima and the  history of the island that was shot I  took right on the beach looking up at  Mount Suribachi where so many  landed in their crafts and where so many  lives were lost these are some of the  immediate rondo high rondo incredible  men who talked about the enormity of the  tasks that they had before them and how  small it made for me the news that  happened on Friday actually feel